there's so many that's a thing when I
it's incredible how much music there if
you know I don't know where to I mean
the first if you just follow one person
it'll lead you to like it's all
connected somehow like when I I was in
high school and I my band director gave
me a Wes Montgomery album - he wanted me
to learn this piece on the guitar for a
talent show and so he gave me this Wes
Montgomery record and that was again I
think of that maybe as a beginning for
me of becoming aware of that music and
it was Wes Montgomery with Ron Carter
playing bass right so who recently I've
been the last to be able to play with
him I can't believe I get to play with
some of these people but so there's this
first record that I really listened to
that's a jazz record and there's Ron
Carter's playing bass so then I go all I
want to get another jazz record so I get
a Kenny Burrell record and there's Ron
Carter's playing bass on that one and
then well I want I get a Miles Davis
record and Ron Carter stay based on that
one and but I mean that you can then Ron
you know plays with Miles Davis and
Miles Davis played with John Coltrane
and John Coltrane played with Duke
Ellington and Duke Ellington played with
Louis Armstrong and I mean it's just it
you have to I don't know what what to
tell somebody if you just start just
listen to anything great listen to the
loneliest monk and Sonny Rollins and
Charlie Parker and Duke Ellington any
any of those guys you can it's easy to
find out who they are and and it it'll
they'll all lead you off in all these
unbelievable it's like this well it's
more than a tree it's like a forest of
just you know all the seeds coming down
from this giant tree and there's it's
it's amazing